[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
accompagner les étudiants et dents
en France les aidants familiaux
représentent 8 à 11 millions de
personnes qui apportent une aide
régulière à titre non professionnel et
non rémunéré dans les activités
quotidiennes ou sur le plan émotionnel à
un proche en perte d'autonomie pour des
raisons liées à l'âge à une maladie ou à
un handicap un étudiant de
l'enseignement supérieur sur 10 serait
aidant or endossé ce rôle qui reste
aujourd'hui trop peu considérés et mal
reconnu est associé à une moins bonne
santé physique et mentale ainsi qu'à une
limitation des opportunités d'éducation
et d'emplois dans ce contexte comment
accompagner ses étudiants aidants
tirailler entre leur aspiration à
réussir leurs études et le souci de
porter assistance à leurs proches
en septembre 2022 Jean-François Rapin a
déposé une proposition de loi visant à
tenir compte dans l'attribution des
bourses de l'enseignement supérieur de
la situation de l'étudiant aidant d'un
parent en situation de handicap son
initiative est née de deux constats
d'une part la prise en charge du
handicap d'un parent à des répercussions
financières sociales et éducatives qui
affectent inévitablement les enfants au
cours de leur scolarité d'autres parts
la reconnaissance et l'accompagnement de
ces jeunes font aujourd'hui défauts le
30 mai 2023 cette proposition de loi a
été adoptée par le Sénat
le texte prévoyait initialement de
verser automatiquement une bourse
d'études échelon 7 aux étudiants dont au
moins l'un des deux parents est porteurs
d'un handicap entraînant un taux
d'incapacité d'au moins 80%. la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication chargée
d'examiner le texte en a précisé et
enrichi la rédaction initiale afin de la
rendre compatible avec la réforme du
système des bourses étudiantes sur
critères sociaux qui sera mise en place
dès la rentrée 2023
l'examen du texte par le Sénat en séance
intervient en effet peu après l'annonce
par le Président de la République lors
de la sixième Conférence nationale du
handicap d'une mesure en faveur des
étudiants aidants de parents handicapés
ou eux-mêmes en situation de handicap
dans le cadre du système de bourse
la Commission a également saisi
l'occasion de cette initiative
sénatoriale en direction des étudiants
aidants pour alerter la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur sur la
nécessité de se saisir d'un autre
chantier indispensable complémentaire à
celui du soutien financier à porté à ces
jeunes adultes celui de l'adaptation de
leur rythme d'étude et de leur
accompagnement le Sénat estime urgent
que le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur mène avec les établissements
un travail de fond sur la prise en
charge des étudiants aidants qui
pourraient donner lieu à un cadrage
national ensuite décliner localement
dans les schémas directeur de la vie
étudiante
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]